hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights okay hey we
just got back from a diabolically
devastating collapse and we're at the
water park oh gee I wonder what ah [ __ ]
you ah I knew it
Oh give me what's in here oh hello
boring boring point
stupid water months hey here's a lever
up I crap
give me a box do it give it give it give
it give it give it mm ow
aha yeah no I like you anyway what
what what is this oil laudanum is that
it crap oh [ __ ] Oh Frick affront ha ha
[ __ ] you ha ha ha do it get away get
away either way you get away I'm not
gonna make it the timer is gonna up the
timer timer timer timer timer timer
timer Tommy let me through let me
through let me through
aha a high wind ah no no I don't have it
I don't I don't have any LaDonna why is
it gonna be an open one a bull oh oh
this looks like it's gonna break
yeah there we go
oh that not one was that just another
was it just a splishy-splash at least
are giving me LaDonna hunts that's
awfully nice of them
surprise that fall didn't kill me I was
already bread well they're two of them
are they just digging around with me are
there two of them oh yeah there's plenty
of boxes you recognition bridge oh no I
can't because I can throw like it I'm so
strong
ah or so okay eat ah there are two of
you but screw you both part huh
give me your head ha ha ha ha ha take it
back
[Music]
oh you're so far bow I had they seemed
fat those blue Jeep lassies are coming
pretty quick damn it oh they were Tula
that's why blue blue blue blue oh okay
alright what was the point of that just
to let me hurt myself was that why I
went down there is that the only reason
are you happy now you bastards
I hate you all not you them not you down
them I hate that okay I could they get
there they got to be leading me like a
key or something I don't know all right
ooh ha no needle okay ah wait wait a
minute what wait wait a minute what was
the point of coming up here I'm not just
gonna go right back down into it aw crap
ah Oh God wasn't there one in here
wasn't there one in here was there not
one in here okay I'm losing my mind
apparently okay I'm okay with that
actually I'm perfectly
okay that's fair this door can be open
with a needle oh I have one of those
right here right cheer haha okay a good
sworn that was one in that room with me
but apparently not oh well it don't
matter it's all good oh wow
now there's something I've never seen
before
holy crap how did he do that I've never
seen that in the game I mean this guy's
English sucks but at least he's really
really trying to make some interesting
level design that is cool a veneer hello
come on door God don't be a douche hello
anybody there hello what behind me oh I
don't like that I don't like that
like pitch-black door okay all right
there's nothing there's nothing oil all
right there's nothing there's nothing
nothing oh this is Becky hi really this
wall of water is blocking me I want to
go through a tall home before enabling
the water pump you need to activate the
cooling system by pulling the lever the
water pump is connected with the cooling
system that makes sense doing this the
wrong way could be catastrophic strophic
all right so lever don't push me away
lever
I'll lever oh you got to be kidding me
without the cooling system it will be a
Tom bomb I have to press the orange
button
no one's button well is the orange
button that a thing looks button desk to
me
whoa what's that up there something
rocking up there whoa all of them are
huh weird okay oh the waters training
okay I guess that's bad the system will
overheat now they'll seem to be on fire
okay why did I need to do that all right
whatever I'm not gonna oh I can get back
here now and there was absolutely
nothing back here what's the point
what's the point of having that oh no I
don't want any you go away you're fat
and you're ugly you are also a dick go
go eat many dicks put many uh hello haha
you can't I can see you but you can't
see me I'm not even doing the looking at
oh hi ha ha ha ha look at that flabby
ass ha ha ha ha I wonder you don't have
a girlfriend
ha ha yeah good out of here loser
leaving
it's your monster Oh still there don't
like it don't like it go away go away no
one likes you I I don't have a chair but
I I will still shove something right up
your butt that sounds weird no no
actually I won't do that I won't do that
at all mr. monster where are you going
running away from me at a medium pace ah
you're still there where you go where
you going where you going where you
going where you going where you going
huh you still there no I think he's gone
I'm not getting any of that warped
vision from looking at someone all right
we're all he's gone okay
[Music]
huh was that it is that a real monster
that was that was one of them fakie
monsters lice I'm surrounded by lies
lies and deceit everyone lies to me well
that did the job now quick before the
boiler explodes quick what quick do what
what do what do I do now hi hi
I saw the hand I freaking saw the hand
what I can't open that now what screw
you
crow yo you get oh that's where I came
in
oh that's right Oh left is where okay
that's blocked anyway oh that's where
the the thing broke ah here we go got it
smart so smart Wow oh [ __ ] the boiler
exploded what do I need to do
nothing apparently I find then ah what
let's film back up with water really
freely move I can't even move I can jump
I can't move though I'm immobile
immobilized I am this won't stop me
which is actually getting really high my
supposed to do something here because I
think I can't seem to move
it's up to my neck now oh okay there we
go
ah crap I can't turn the lantern on
that's phenomenal
okay I know they're gonna throw another
water
I know it I know it I knew it I knew it
I knew it I knew it I know it [ __ ] yo
damn door
get out oh don't be a pole do you pull
[ __ ] you and your pole ah shut up shut
up shut up tips I don't need your sass
are you son of them oh why didn't that
door closed screw closing your doors
screw closing the doors I swear no it's
open now I'll close it
barely any door left dad that doors gone
and now this doors gonna go on
right ah oh good thing that door was
there
good thing I closed that door all right
no more collapses no more douchiness
okay
ah sighs ah that's okay he's waving
he's odd or get open now get close I'm
gonna assume that close I'm gonna open
I'm gonna close
uh-huh did it just break
it's not fair not fair not fair not fair
not fair you all that's old
you all right all of you
[Music]
okay now all right I guess I just go up
that's pretty pretty specular
reflections find out they're not the
right term but something like that all
right all right I really really do
appreciate the amount of you know
customization this this moderates done
he really has done something special
don't trust that doors Oh finally some
peace oh hello baby
Oh like this
oh I realized I didn't find anyone here
where are they I got all the company I
need uh your legs go for miles baby oh
yeah oh hello what do you think huh
hello baby nothing nothing at all
Oh another one hello how are you today
punch head butt alright nothing back
there big painting big painting big
painting boxes there doesn't seem to be
anything up here shadow I've got that
strange feeling again in this dark place
I better be pay attention now I better
be paying attention now man this guy's
English that's okay though okay I'm
gonna hold off on going down in the
darkness just yet okay join Mike one
I'm guessing a door mark - yes
a piano hired piano not just this calm
background music which is very relaxing
but for three oh okay alright so we got
four four mark doors and a shadowy area
let's go in the shadow area at first not
that I want to but just on the bottom
floor but actually that's gonna have to
wait until the next episode thank you
all so much for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next part but I